restrictions have he eased here in the
las vegas valley and we're also seeing
that at gyms today marx has started the
first full week without the universal
mass mandate here in nevada it is a
welcome sign for those who grew
frustrated with the rules at local gyms
victoria saha takes us into a couple
gyms around town to see how they're
welcoming back members
barbells are not the only thing being
dropped as gym members now have the
option to drop those masks i felt more
comfortable i felt as if freedom monday
was terry steele's first workout at the
ymca without a mask in nearly two years
i sometimes have to gas for air and take
in a lot of air and i'm pulling the
cloth of the mask into my mouth and it's
uncomfortable at the ymca near meadows
lane in south valley members are
trickling back in we've seen traffic
pick up a bit over the last few days and
some are still keeping the mask on with
my age my daughter worries about me all
the time so i just she would like me to
wear it and so i'm doing it and you know
i've actually become accustomed to it
though many people are here working out
without a mask the directors here say
that the cardio machines here are going
to stay four feet apart to add that
extra layer of safety at venus hot yoga
their classes are packed inhale upward
facing dog look forward we've actually
doubled our numbers
just this morning alone
a phone allowing for a big breath of
fresh air in a room that reaches 105
degrees feels much better
complete like
100 percent difference victoria saha
live local now